[Music]
[Music]
was it my dream to become a spy no
it wasn't my dream to become aspires
very young i never
thought about spying or spies or the
spying world
yes it was the job that chose me how did
i find out that i was recruited
the first day of school eight o'clock in
the morning and the
big man at the head of the table said
welcome to the institute
and i was shocked i couldn't believe it
i really almost fell off the chair
[Music]
the first day that i came and they told
me where i was i said
why was i accepted to this school
didn't seem logical what made me
suitable for the job
was things that they saw in me that i
didn't even know about myself
the strength the ability to be by myself
the ability to be open-minded to see
things through
to understand them to see people and
understand who they are
and what to expect of them things like
that
when i recruited people when i asked
them what do you think
you need to become a spy many people say
you have to be fearless so i say no no
no
you have to be afraid because it's one
of your tools
when you feel fear you have to translate
it is it connected to you
is it connected to the surroundings if
it comes from your instincts
about the mission about the job then you
have to take it seriously and understand
it
you must feel the fear but you must
continue doing what you do
with that fear if you're stopped by the
fear
it means you're not suited for the job
i wasn't really finished with studying
in school but i was needed because at
that time
there were hardly any women on the job
they needed a woman and i went
we got to the airport and first thing is
passport control
and i'm standing in the queue and i'm
scared
and i realized that i couldn't remember
my name
the name in the passport it took me a
while
took me a few seconds a minute i don't
even know how how long it was
but then i thought about it calmed down
remembered my name and went through
passport control
second time was not really scared but
nervous and the third time
i really did it with no problem
normally you just go through it you do
what you need to do
can you teach somebody not to be scared
you can try
you need to know how to manage your fear
in order to
manage your fear you need to be very
focused and to understand what you're
doing there
and why you're there you need to control
the fear
some things you can't teach you can
teach technical things
you can teach people how to speak a
proper language
proper accent how to follow people how
to find out if you are being followed
how to take good photos you can learn
lots of things which i will not go into
but
these are the skills of being a spy
and the rest is you in this job
everybody's different i mean we're all
different
i don't think you'll find one person
similar or exactly the same like the
other
the institute uses differences between
people because
you have so many missions so many
different
people to do different jobs everybody
has their own way
to play
darknet
when you go on a mission you need to
know that you might be caught you might
find yourself interrogated
being tortured even can you prepare
yourself to be interrogated
yes you can but when it's for real
you never know how you will react at the
real moment
the institute always knows that you
might speak
and you can look back at stories that
happened people were caught
and people told their stories and some
didn't
it's not a fantasy there is fear and the
rest is you
you